that's because you were being an arse
I'm his wife not his sub not some
company he's acquired I'm not the crack whore who was his mother
you know you're topping from the bottom
he murmurs against my lips
I don't understand what he's talking about
Carlie Tango
she's a Eurocopter EC 135
The safest in its class
dios mio double crap me and my two left
feet
Two hands, that's double exasperation
I thought it was chocolate fudge brownie
sex we had
with a cherry on top but hey what do I know
Charlie Tango
she's a Eurocopter EC 135
the safest in its class
what does that mean
does he white slave small children to
some godforsaken part of the planet
is he part of some underworld crime
syndicate it would explain why he's so
rich
is he deeply religious?
Is he impotent?
surely not he could prove that to
me right now
I'm a sadist Bella
I like to whip little brown hair girls
like you because you
like the crack whore my birth mother
what are the safety stats on the convertible?
I like to come as I please he smirks
and cranks his glorious smile up another
notch so it's in full HD IMAX
Baby, it's gonna take more than a malfunctioning one thirty five to keep me away from you
One thirty five?
Charlie Tango
she's a Eurocopter EC 135
The safest in its class